[Music]
some people think they think for the top
story tonight is President Obama's State
of the Union address or the upcoming
Super Bowl that's what they think but
judging by local news there's an even
bigger story that's sweeping the nation
news you know the old expression don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
be happy don't worry be happy don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
be happy don't worry be happy don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy about doing fear and sang it we
think don't worry don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
be happy don't worry be happy don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
be happy
yeah Bobby McFerrin made a lot of money
off then don't worry be happy don't
worry be happy don't worry be happy
don't worry be happy don't worry be
happy don't worry be happy don't worry
be happy don't worry be happy don't
worry be happy we're listening to it
during the break